previously on coffeezilla we're not
gonna take millions of dollars to [ __ ]
our fans ever bro
we won't take any sponsorship money
nothing bro like i can't i don't do that
for selling t-shirts
it's actually impossible now coffee now
is there
a way where it's like to just make
this like right
[Music]
so
would you do it oh most definitely do
you see where i'm working 12 million
dollars a year would go a long way yeah
that's exactly the problem though money
can make people do almost anything if i
had 12 million dollars i'd go crazy the
first thing i do is buy pants lots and
lots of pants i mean for that kind of
money people can justify literally
anything
i don't even think people notice to be
honest all they see is the shirt but
it's surprisingly drafty back here and i
just feel i need to commit one way or
the other people are committing crime
i'm wait are you listening to me oh
sorry coffee something something ethical
dilemma right
look let me help you you've got these
guys by the balls right but what you
need is i don't like where this is going
you gotta squeeze them hard coffee like
a pair of tight jeans all right yeah
i've heard enough i'm leaving no wait
i'm serious what i mean is there can't
be breathing room for these influencers
like a nice new pair of tight jeans you
gotta make an airtight case here
starting with why this whole offshore
thing is unethical in the first place
come on you don't think the audience
already knows that we're talking about
your average milk viewer
oh that's a good point okay i think
you're right
i'm gonna go back to the 10 million
dollar studio and work on this
thanks for the drinks i'll pay the tab
next time yeah yeah internet detective
ladies and gentlemen the reasons pushing
gambling on people is bad is obvious but
i still want to explain it for people
who still might have questions like this
what's the difference between steve
promoting rubet and literally every
sports broadcasting network promoting
sports betting you know what it's a
valid point both are gambling and with
gambling yes you're gonna lose money and
gambling addiction is a very real thing
people's lives are ruined especially
from things like slots but this isn't a
dare presentation okay there is another
side to this you know gambling can be a
lot of fun so i want to make it clear
i'm not against gambling i'm not anti
sports betting i'm anti promoting fake
high stakes gambling to young audiences
from illegal jurisdictions with little
or no help for gambling addicts i hope
that clears my position up
all right fine let me break this down a
bit let's start with the fake money
these streamers use or sponsored money
as it's called you know i've heard a lot
of people say that these streams
promoting gambling is the same as
promoting any vice like smoking or
drinking the same way that there's laws
with drinking
smoking right right it's advice and this
simply isn't true for one when
advertising most devices you're at least
taking on the same risks of the vice as
the people you're promoting that vice to
for example if you're a streamer and you
want to be sponsored by a cigarette
company and you're being paid every time
someone picks up smoking part of the
deal would be you'd have to smoke and
that smoking would give you cancer just
as fast as the people you're promoting
it to but with casinos and fake money
that isn't the case is it the price of a
gambling vice isn't a hangover or bad
lungs it's just being poor and broke and
when you're playing with fake money
you don't have that problem and we know
these streamers are aware of that fact
because they've been literally caught
talking about it if i started like
putting my own money in this i feel like
i feel like if i just filled myself
before thousands like right
like i feel like i could like
but also it could it could be dangerous
but i see that there's no point of
putting my body in your mind through
that type of stress
don't need the stress don't want to put
your body through that kind of stress
these guys are unreal steve is literally
saying here the thing that i'm putting
my fans through i would never go through
myself i mean
who needs it i don't need it and by the
way just so we're clear the people
maddest about this fake money stuff it
really isn't me it's actually the real
money gamblers who know how ridiculous
these fake high-stakes gambling
streamers are i'm considering these
sites scamming with all their fake
[ __ ] pieces [ __ ] streamers how dumb
are you
you think these guys are betting 70
million dollars a day you are
[ __ ] dumb and stupid
wow sometimes it really isn't what you
say
it's how you say it all right fine if
the ethical thing really doesn't get you
up in the morning how about the fact
that many of these people are literally
illegally gambling in the u.s and know
their fans are gonna do the same for
example here's steve in his miami condo
no no wait pause right there do you see
that
howler head whiskey logo pay attention
because in some of steve's gambling
streams you could see the same logo from
the background which is weird because i
thought he was going to mexico this is
illegal because rubet can't operate in
the us but here steve is in miami
playing on rubet but of course these
guys don't really care and of course the
same is true for aiden ross we've caught
him as well
in america gambling here he is in his
room
on dual bits so what does this actually
mean though well it means that the fans
of these streamers who are sometimes
gambling in the u.s then go out and use
a vpn to also gamble from the us and
they discuss this pretty openly quote
it's banned in the u.s use a vpn they
know their users are using a vpn as long
as they enforce global laws they are
safe so they don't stop you from using a
vpn at happy i'm broke lol any good vpns
i'm a djin gambler wasted 94k you can
just use a vpn i've wagered effing 300k
on rubet and made steve rich off
referrals guys can you play live games
on rubet with a vpn yes
but just in case none of that convinced
you i've saved my best argument for last
my trap card if you will for all these
gambling streamers the one thing that
they will be unable to defend offshore
crypto casinos are completely
indefensible because of their lack of
iding people and responsible gambling
controls because right now if you're a
gambling addict you can go to your local
casino and ban yourself if you have a
problem it's a very common practice
called self-exclusion but online crypto
casinos don't let you do that as
gambling addicts who i interviewed told
me yeah so i think that the biggest
problem is like typically with any other
regulated gambling site
you have
self-imposed restrictions you sign up to
it they take your details and they ban
you from any gambling websites betting
websites anything like that and it's
brilliant that was probably the thing
that
that enforced my recovery the most
because
you know as much as i wanted to gamble i
couldn't if you tried to make a new
account
you can't
you'll last for about one second before
the system says hey no this is you and
you have a gambling problem
with crypto casinos it's
it's not that they don't really care why
would they have to care
they're in curacao they don't have to
worry about i mean yeah no doubt eh i
mean i didn't have to give a passport
any kind of id
any kind of verification of who i was so
you know i could have been a child and
it just so happened i was a vulnerable
adult i mean you can close your account
they'll do it for you but you can sign
up with a new email under
the exact same id that you just uploaded
not even a different picture the exact
picture and uh continue on your way a
lot of people talk about the harm to
children that this might bring but
there's a lot of adults out there who
have a gambling disorder which is a
brain disorder and they're being prayed
on by one of the most exploitative and
profit-making
industries
it's it's absolutely sick in my opinion
he's right this is the real problem with
offshore gambling in curacao the fact
that anyone from anywhere regardless of
their age or if they're addicted to
gambling they can just jump on these
casinos any time and by the way that
doesn't just apply to rubet it also
applies to steak and dual bits as well
all of these crypto casinos located
offshore and these companies the reason
they make recovery for gambling addicts
a million times harder because they
don't let themselves exclude the reason
they do that it makes them more money
and because they're offshore nobody can
tell them otherwise why would you turn a
potential customer away after all a
gambling addict is a great customer for
a casino and the craziest part is that
this shady scummy business is being
pushed not by criminals not on the dark
web but by the biggest streaming
platform and influencers in the world
and why have you ever asked yourself why
are almost all the top streamers all
sponsored by crypto casinos instead of
more regulated casinos the answer is
actually quite simple offshore casinos
have less regulation which means more
customers allowed in which means more
money which means more money to spend on
influencers which means they get the
contract right it's actually pretty
simple when you think about it but
remember where that extra money is
coming from from gambling addicts and
people who shouldn't be gambling in the
first place at this point i want to
confront steve will do it already you
know we've talked to nelk already now
it's time for steve but before we can do
that we need to find some hard evidence
to confront him with and i realized i
still have questions so i started
digging around and i created this let's
go to the conspiracy board real quick so
this is rubet or at least the money
flowing into rupet the center is what we
call rubet's hot wallet on ethereum
where all the money flows in and the
outside are all the wallets depositing
money into the casino and the reason i
made this wait why did i make this oh
yeah because it looks cool and because
it demonstrates the scope of rhubarb's
operation because the first thing i
wanted to know is how much money is
rubet making right how much are any of
these crypto casinos making and so
tracking the money that flows in is a
big part but of course casinos don't
keep all the money that flows in only
what players lose so in order to
estimate the profit we also need to see
the money flowing
out and so i made this these are some
wallets that some ordinary gamers and i
tracked down as being key to some of the
owners of rubet we'll talk more in part
six about how we did this and who owns
these wallets but for now just know this
gives us a very rough idea of how much
money these guys are making
in total all these crypto wallets over
here deposited a total of 1.2 billion
dollars in ethereum into rubit and over
here the top 10 ethereum wallets many of
which are owned by the owners of rubet
have pulled out 300 million dollars of
that meaning i should start an
unregulated crypto casino i'm just
kidding no actually it just means that
this is an insanely lucrative business
obviously and this is only ethereum we
haven't even calculated bitcoin yet
which is probably worth more it's just a
little harder to get an exact number on
that for reasons i won't bore you with
but the point is not only are they
making a lot but we also know the crypto
casinos are a low expense business
meaning most of it is profit really the
only cost is licensing the slot machines
paying some employees and really
marketing with these influencers
ultimately all these casinos care about
is getting more numbers on the board
more people in the door it's a very
simple game for them so this is where
influencers come in right these guys
actually are the lifeblood of these
casinos they're the ones who drive fresh
meat into these casinos to gamble which
explains
why they get paid so much and by the way
just so we're all clear rubet which we
focused on because the biggest clowns
promote it isn't the biggest crypto
casino actually rubet is the baby
brother of the offshore casino world but
in the way that shaq is maybe the baby
brother of yao ming he's still massive
but you know it's just all relative the
truth is there's an even bigger crypto
casino we haven't talked about steak
think about it this way ruben has done 2
billion wagers on their site by
comparison stake has done 45 billion
wagers making steak over 20 times larger
and a billion dollar business so maybe a
good comparison isn't shaq and yao ming
but more like peter dinklage and yao
ming either way they're both absolutely
raking in the money now you may know
steak because of the influencers like
train wrecks who gamble with them
they're really no better at all than
rubet especially with the kyc issue
which we've already flagged as being the
most important thing these people just
let gambling addicts in and ruin their
lives but many of them many of these
influencers will claim that they tell
people not to gamble to not bet more
than they lose are these influencers
really impacting anybody well to find
that out let's go to the main desk
sorted out but here's the thing i wanted
to know exactly how much of an impact
these streamers were having so i decided
i needed to dig into affiliate numbers
remember these are the codes that these
guys give you like code steve will do it
code bradley martin code logan paul's
friend these numbers tell us exactly how
many people these guys are bringing into
these casinos now luckily for us steve
will do it in particular accidentally
leaked these numbers in a stream not
once but twice
once in april of 2020 and once in may of
2021 actually giving us a really nice
one-year sample size of how many people
someone like steve will do it will bring
in a given year so here's his numbers
from april one year ago you can see he
has almost no deposits only 173
depositors and 546 deposits this was at
the beginning of his streaming career
but fast forward a year later and this
guy has 22 000 unique depositors and
these people have deposited 324 000
times in total now if we zoom in here
and actually have the computer enhance
we find that steve will do it has made
1.7 million dollars off of affiliate
codes alone so let's understand what
this means steve is a mid-sized to large
gambling streamer and in one year he
brought in 22 000 new accounts and those
people deposited on average about 15
times each and mathematically three to
five percent will become problem
gamblers or addicts which means steve
onboarded about 600 to 1100 gambling
addicts in one year going off the
statistics good job steve and the price
for doing that was 1.7 million dollars
but of course that isn't the only way
steve made money from reubet that's just
affiliates he's making much more but it
was hard pinning down his income exactly
we found a bunch of other things like
his ethereum deposit wallets and a
bitcoin deposit wallet but every time we
confronted steve with a wallet we
thought belonged to him it was like
patrick starr and manta ray in spongebob
aren't you steve will do it
and this is you playing rhubarb
i found this deposit wallet in your
stream and if that's the case this
wallet belongs to you that makes sense
to me
then take accountability it's not my
wallet
yeah suffice to say i was going crazy
okay you know here's this guy saying
he's gonna be a billionaire in three to
five years but in dms it's a totally
different story ladies and gentlemen
steve told me not only is he not a
billionaire he told me he doesn't even
have a million dollars he sent me a
screenshot of his bank account to prove
it
quote i don't even have a million
dollars and he said right after that
look at my youtube videos bro look at
how much i spend look at how my parents
live and what they have i'm not claiming
to make a little i'm telling you i spend
100 of what i have on my youtube videos
i haven't saved a dollar in like five
months now okay i'll be honest i felt
this was a bit of a cop-out right he's
claiming to spend 100 of what he makes
on youtube videos but his youtube videos
are just him spending money on assets
like watches and properties i mean are
they dumb purchases
yes but in watches alone he spent two
million dollars in two months two months
steve spent two and a half million he's
crazy touching three almost after this
week so when steve says he hasn't saved
money in five months he means cash but
he has gained
assets however dumb they are and i
confronted steve on this and he told me
quote i own seven cars but bought 20 for
other people i own nine watches but i've
gifted ten i own four properties but
i've gifted three properties away and i
replied so you're worth more than three
million dollars oh my gosh this is
making no sense he says you don't
understand my youtube channel
now he is right about that i don't
understand it but even though he's worth
way more than a million dollars i really
did kind of think this was a bit
pathetic i mean it reminded me of these
professional athletes that make millions
of dollars and end up broke like i mean
this guy's taking private jets flexing
watches but at the end of the day he's
spending everything and it just all
struck me as so pointless like
especially when considering where the
money came from getting his fans
addicted to gambling now before we go
further there's one other thing i should
mention and it's that steve told me that
he made so much money on rubet not just
because of the gambling but because of
what he had been doing for whizza
as well he told me it in dms you don't
even know why i make so much i asked why
he replied i promote whizza completely
free that's the only reason i make money
off ruben i was offered a bag not
cryptocurrency for promotion of wiza i
said no because i can't do that in
youtube because my whole thing is no
paid ads on youtube that's why when i go
to mexico i was able to stream with 1 to
2k viewers and make good money off
stream wow it is true that steve
constantly is telling people how much he
promotes wiza for free because they're
his buddies i'm doing this for them
they're paying me zero dollars i know
like there's been some controversy to
talk about this like wizard thing right
yeah and and i know firsthand
like that you do not collect money from
that because you're grateful for the
other opportunities that the people who
who like basically created that company
gave you but what he's telling us here
contradicts that he's simply saying
because he doesn't take a paycheck with
wizza he gets more of a paycheck over on
ruben which totally contradicts wizz's
whole point to myself and mudahar that
they're totally separate from ruben
remember wizard this whole time has been
trying to convince everybody that them
and rubet are completely separate
entities but steve will do it is saying
very clearly that his relationship with
rubet is dependent on how much he
promotes wiza he said it even more
explicitly later on quote i only started
to make good money because i would do
these wiza ads for free like if i would
have accepted taking money from wizard
my rubet numbers would be significantly
lower hmm poking a few holes in wiz's
story there but at this point i realized
it was kind of going in circles trying
to get him to fess up to how much money
he's making it was time to quit the
foreplay i decided i needed to get steve
will do it on the phone and i decided to
ask him the golden question can you just
tell me how much you're making on brew
bet like is it 1 million a month is it 2
million a month what is it i mean it's
really like how much like how like how
much do i am i able to go and travel
it's whatever like i really want it not
what i want it to be like it can't be
like a lot but yeah i mean it could be
it could be like
to sometimes like
closer to the million like per month wow
annualized that's six to 12 million
dollars a year pretty wild especially
since he's probably lowballing this
either way it's insane 12 million
dollars a year to spin some slots on
twitch but the craziest part of this
conversation came when steve started
talking about why he even partnered with
rubet in the first place you won't
believe this it's just one of those
things i love to gamble i gambled a lot
it kind of was kind of disgusting
and it was kind of like a great
you know a great way for me to
not gamble with my own money right
what he partnered with a gambling
company as a way to gamble without
spending his own money it seems insane
and like do you see that as a problem i
mean because i literally have a clip of
you being like you know i i i thought
about putting my own money in but who
needs that kind of stress and it's like
oh this is insane because basically what
you're doing you're an ambassador for a
company trying to get your fans to
gamble with their own money but then you
yourself don't want to gamble with your
money you don't you know what i mean you
know how that comes off
yeah though i hear what you're saying i
i mean i do gamble as in sports and [ __ ]
still but i do i do get what you're
saying i just um
i stopped playing at the casino
why
because i have no control man and i have
a and what is it a credit
no control
i mean i gamble
if i go to a casino i gamble and now
it's like
little money but but wait but wait but
don't you see the problem there is like
if you're saying like oh man i gotta
stop gambling i have no control and then
you're making
the majority of your money from getting
other people to gamble while you
yourself
don't really want to do it anymore like
isn't that kind of like a problem
um
it's it's definitely it it could be a
problem because gambling's not good
wow
uh not good is right steve is admitting
here that not only does he have a
gambling problem his solution was to get
a gambling sponsorship so that he
wouldn't have to stop gambling but now
his losses are just his fans losses and
he makes a ton of money it's insane now
to steve's credit unlike a lot of other
gambling influencers he didn't shy away
from the fact that oh yeah this is bad
but again what's weird here is and i
couldn't believe it during the
conversation it seems that steve never
seems to have had this thought before
that offshore gambling might be bad in
fact not only has apparently he never
thought of it he says no one in his
inner circle of friends ever mentioned
it either maybe if you were like my
friend like in real life and you no
one's approached me and said anything
like this that hey steve
you know what you're doing is wrong
this uh you know i've never been
approached like that
you know
yeah
like you know no one's even he's close
to me he's ever said like yo like you
should really rethink what you're doing
it's wrong you know i've never had that
and i never thought that i was doing
anything wrong
personally
this is just sad honestly you know i
can't read steve's mind i'll say right
up front he could definitely be lying
about this whole thing but i don't know
if that's the case here based on what
i've seen if steve will do it i believe
he actually thought to himself oh i'm
the good guy i'm not one of those
scammers i'm the good guy and it was
weird to hear him sort of in real time
it's sinking in that oh maybe this
rubette stuff was really bad now coffee
now is there
a way where it's like to just make
this like right
like we like because i'm i'm i'm i'm not
here saying oh
no nothing's wrong with gambling and
[ __ ] like like
is there a way to make this right with
you
like i mean i'm because i'm here i don't
need to do
rubet ever again
wow i don't know about you but if there
was ever a confession that's it steve
admitted here that what he was doing is
wrong and that he would quit he later
says it even more explicitly well no
i've already made i've already made that
decision
like before saying that is right if i
thought like it's already that's already
decided uh you're done with rhubarb
yeah i mean unless i
unless there's a way to do it right but
yeah right now i'm
done i mean unless you get on the phone
and be like hey this is how you do it
right
let's be honest is steve doing this
mostly because he got caught and not all
because of some ethics realization yeah
probably let's not be naive this is good
for steve's brand to stop gambling at
this point but nonetheless would steve
quitting offshore gambling be a good
gesture yes because ultimately this
isn't a story about steve will do it
making millions even though it might
have started that way this has become a
story about the gambling addicts who are
suffering because of the offshore crypto
casinos who are relentlessly targeting
them and even one influencer standing up
stopping and saying this was wrong that
matters however that being said there
was another part of me that after this
call i couldn't help but think that
steve is just one influencer in a chain
of influencers all of them attracted by
insane money and not willing to look at
the result of their own actions and
willing to look the other way and the
problem is it's sort of an endless
supply of steves as soon as one steve
will do it won't do it another steve
will do it you know what i mean i
learned this when talking about that
aidan ross clip i put on twitter that
clip of aiden ross demeaning himself in
front of tens of thousands of people and
i said would you do this for one meal a
month and i meant it as a joke but the
answer was overwhelming basically y'all
all would and that kind of seems obvious
in hindsight but it made me look at this
case a little bit differently and it
brought back some things people had told
me along the way about how to approach
this whole thing
we can do what hassan and ethan did and
spend hours arguing with trainwreck
about you know how
morally bad this is and you shouldn't be
doing this but
if somebody came to me tomorrow and said
i'm going to pay you a million dollars a
month i'd say yeah
you know even in my position as somebody
who's been through
the harm that gambling can cause
you know i understand that people need
money that's a really good point if
ultimately the goal is to stop offshore
gambling preying on addicts how do we
solve that is it by showing people
getting their lives ruined by gambling
because i can do that i've talked to so
many gambling addicts over the last week
and some of their stories were so brutal
that i was literally at a loss for words
how much money are you in debt right now
more than 30 000
i can't sleep and they have like people
i need to pay by the end of the month
and i'm just like
mentally completely
completely
destroyed and
i
before i called you i was watching the
video how to end your life that's how
that's how bad is getting into me right
now i'm like um i feel like so stupid it
got dark and i can show you over and
over and over again clips that would
horrify you these people are saying the
same thing they're relapsing because
unregulated gambling doesn't let
themself exclude i can make that case
five ways till friday about why
unregulated gambling is bad and i might
convince a few people or maybe shame a
few influencers into quitting this
garbage practice of selling out your
fans but again we know there's always
going to be some scumbag willing to look
the other way because it's life-changing
money so what do we do
obviously i'm no expert in this stuff so
i decided instead to just ask the
addicts i talked to what do they think
should be done i think twitch need to
stop every stripper that promote
unregulated casinos i mean personally
i'm i'm in favor of just shutting it
down on twitch altogether simple as that
promote casino that there are regulated
beings i can play on them and if i if
you know if if i think i'm becoming an
addict it would shut your account and
things like that i don't think
uh a platform with
a platform that knows that the
percentage of young people on their
platform
is what 17 20 whatever it was
they shouldn't be allowing this
especially not promoting it suggesting
it so there you go that's what they say
should be done and for what it's worth i
agree twitch needs to do something and i
think they understand that because
they've already been removing gambling
affiliate codes from their influencers
pages but is that enough ultimately for
an industry that is completely dependent
on influencer marketing twitch could
make some big changes that would
radically help gambling addicts and lead
to more compliance worldwide because
let's be honest if these billion dollar
crypto casinos knew for example that it
wouldn't be tolerated on twitch for them
to not check ids or allow vpns you
better believe they would change their
rules and shape up they have enough
money to do proper compliance they have
billions of dollars the only reason they
don't do anything is because twitch
doesn't care right now but i don't mean
to ignore influencers here either
because the solution involves them too
we've shown today with numbers how many
people this is hurting and we've
demonstrated that without these
influencers these casinos wouldn't work
so if you're an influencer you can be
part of the solution too just consider
not partnering with offshore unregulated
casinos but hey that's just my
suggestion and what do i know i'm just a
guy in his 10 million dollar studio
doing my research
research that is about finished waiting
for this drink maxwell come on what has
happened to this place's service oh and
like you're one to talk about making
people wait here you go speedy gonzales
don't forget to pay your tab this time
thanks and sorry listen the reason i'm
in here is i want to tell you about a
little project i've been working on
secretly never been released
tell me it's an actual flying lambo and
not just that cgi looking thing no it's
not an actual
what are you really breaking the wall
right now i don't have time for this
we're literally ending the video no it's
not a flying lamborghini
it's actually
the last episode in this series part six
coming soon guys you thought it was over
it's not we'll see you next time on some
ordinary gamers with reubets house of
cards
[Music]
you